بينما تعمل الوساطات الدوليه والاقليميه
على التهدئه السياسيه بين طرفي النزاع في
السودان تعكس المجريات على الارض صوره
مختلفه فالقتال في السودان ما زال مستمرا
رغم الهدنه الطويله لتسمع اصوات
الاشتباكات جنوب ووسط العاصمه الخرطوم
بالاخص في منطقه السوق العربي ومحيط
المطار وافاد شهود عيان بتحليق طائرات
حربيه وسماع يدوي انفجار قوي واصوات اسلحه
ثقيله في محيط القصر الرئاسي والقياده
العامه للجيش كما شنت الطائرات ضربات جويه
في حي الرياض بالخرطوم لم ينحصر استمرار
الصراع في تلك المنطقه بل سمع دوي
انفجارات وتحليق للطيران الحربي في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري واشتباكات متفرقه في منطقتي
كافوري وشرق النيل بالاضافه لاصوات مضادات
الطيران في اندرمان
اتهامات متبادله بين الطرفين النزاع بخرق
الهدنه فالجيش السوداني اتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بارسال تعزيزات للخرطوم بينما اكدت
الجهه الاخرى شن غارات من قبل الجيش
السوداني على مناطق لقوات الدعم السريع
والتي بدورها حاولت استهداف قياده قوات
الدفاع الجوي
وفي ظل الاشتباكات المستمره فتح الباب
امام عمليات النهب والحرق على وجه الخصوص
في المنطقه الصناعيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
وضع يعكس تصريحات طرفي الصراع باستعدادهما
لمناقشه الهدنه والوضع الانساني دون
الالتزام بوقف النهائي لاطلاق النار ايفا
عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات